if you're dealing with a problem
especially a disease or something or a
mental illness
and you have no idea where to start and
you have somebody you can pay who says
they'll help you
that's way easier than figuring it out
by yourself now it turns out
that's not necessarily easier in the
long run
especially if they're they don't end up
helping you and just saying they can
help you
um but i can understand why people would
take that and we're taught that
that you can go out and find someone who
will solve your problems for you
but in my experience anyway that isn't
true so if you've been
going in one direction for a really long
time and you're still not better
it might just be on you which is scary
but
people are pretty pretty powerful